et pour parler de ce procès nous sommes
en direct avec didier combo docteur en
civilisation américaine dédiée combo
merci d'être en direct avec nous ce
matin alors on entre aujourd'hui dans le
vif du sujet puisque on entame à
minneapolis les débats de fond à quoi
s'attendre dans les prochains jours les
prochaines semaines est ce que il promet
d'être long et complexe procès oui
bonjour oui effectivement il promet
d'être des pions et complexe
surtout qu'il intervient dans une
situation très tendue à la question des
violences policières est une question de
premier plan aux etats unis puisque en
2020 il y allume 1127 personnes ne tué
par la police
et donc ce procès il est symbolique de
de l'action que peut avoir la justice
dans le domaine de la condamnation des
policiers beaucoup de militants
contestent le fait que les policiers
soient soient rarement rendu responsable
de l'insecte donc ça va être un procès
qui va être très suivi en plus il était
déguisé et on peut s'attendre à ce qu'il
soit assez long puisque puisque bien sûr
ces enjeux sont très élevés alors c'est
à coup sûr l'un des des grands procès un
de ces dernières années un procès aussi
important car il est peut-être un peu le
symbole du racisme policiers aux états
unis oui parce que parmi ces c'est plus
de 1000 personnes qui sont tuées par la
police chaque année il y a environ un
quart d'afro américains alors que ce
afro américains ne représente que 10% de
la population
donc ce problème c'est un problème qui
n'est pas seulement un problème de
racisme de la part de la 2d police
américaine puisqu'il ya dix-huit mille
département de police indépendance états
unis et pas seulement un problème de
racisme c'est aussi un problème de
violence mais les afro américains sont
beaucoup plus victimes de cette violence
ils ont à un homme afro-américains trois
fois plus de risques d'être tué par la
police
quinquin
blanc donc c est une question qui qui
est très central aux états unis parce
que c'était une question qui s'est faite
la violence qui vient ce surinfectée les
questions de raffi sur quoi enfin ou
plutôt comment va se passer la ligne de
défense de derrick chauvine on sait que
son avocat en tout cas a plaidé non
coupable
il affirme que voilà georges floyd était
était sous médicaments à ce moment là
notamment et qu'il avait fait en réalité
une overdose de fentanyl oui alors toute
la question ce procès c'est en fait
l'articulation entre cet événement
précis et cette question de dudu du
racisme systémique qui est dénoncé dans
la société américaine
les les tenant d'une condamnation de
derek lowe fine veulent surtout en faire
un exemple mais la justice bien entendu
ne prend pas des décisions pour
l'exemple elle doit se prononcer sur un
cas particulier et ce cas particulier
est peut-être moins complexes l'autre
parce que on l'a la scène a été filmée
et elle durera plus de plus de 9 minutes
et donc on peut penser que l'on peut
difficilement trouver des excuses à ce
policier ce que va mettre en avant la
défense un comme ça bien été vers votre
reportage c'est le fait que georges
klein se remémore n'ont pas de l'action
du policier mais de 2 et 38 de la dronne
qu'il aurait consommé auparavant donc ça
va être un pro c'est intéressant dans la
mesure où il met en
en lumière cette cette opposition entre
le cap personnel cette action
personnelle du policier georges floyd et
les le problème plus général de la
violence politique
une dernière question mi mars on sait
que la famille de georges floyd a été
dédommagé à hauteur de 27 millions de
dollars par la mairie de minneapolis
est-ce que voilà cette somme ce
dédommagement pourrait influencer ou pas
les jurés et oui parce que si la la la
ville défi de dédommager la famille on
peut penser que la ville considère que
le le le département de police pour être
tenu pour responsable
cela dit c'est plus compliqué que ça
parce que dans les affaires civiles
il a la charge de la preuve est
inférieur aux affaires pénales donc on
peut très bien être condamné à verser
des dommages et intérêts tout en n'étant
pas condamnés au pénal et donc est ce
sens sont deux choses différentes
d'autre part il n'y a pas eu de jugement
un ses 27 millions de dollars
c'est un arrangement négocié pour éviter
d'aller en justice donc ça n'a pas été
véritablement une condamnation ma vie
mais ça peut ressembler tout de même un
aveu de culpabilité
merci beaucoup en tout cas didier combo
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes docteur en
civilisation américaine